THE LAST GAME AND SO THE
RIGHT-HANDED SHOT THE GOAL AND
GARLAND OUT AND IN FRONT AND,
OH, GLOVE
HAD TO MISS TIME BECAUSE OF
INJURY AND HAM THE -- TO FIND
OUT NOW AS DALLAS ICES THAD THI,
MYERS NOW, THE P
MILLER, OKAY, THAT HAS TO BE
HARDER THAN THAT.
IT HAS TO GOIME,NE WHERE IT LOOW
SQUIRTING FREE AND HÖGLANDER HAS
L
GET THEIR F FS.
>> John G.: WE SPOKE ABOUT THE
PENALTY KILLING, HOW DO
PAVELSKI, SUTER AGAIN AND HE
TRIED TO SET UP PAVELSK
THERE, MAINTAINING CONTROL. THE
SHIFTY MOVES OF HÖGLANDER
IT GO TO
WITH 9:40 INTO THEHE
MIDDLE.
AND GLE OF FAKSA.
AND WINNING LINE
AND HE H
HANDLE, TWO-ON-ONE, GARLAND,
PODKOLZIN, SCORES! PODKOLZIN WAN
THAT KNEE-ON-KNEE AND KLINGBERG
NOW, GOOD JOB TO
FREEZE THAT PUCK AND A LONG
WRISTEUCK
AND IT IS A SHOT, REBOUND,
PAVELSKI, STOPPED TO HUGHES
AND
>> John G.: NO, INTO CHANCE.
JUST SHOOT IT FIRST.
THE STARS,
DALLAS TRAILING BY TWO AND IT IS
KLINGBERG HERE TO HEISKANEN.
>> John S.: AND THAT IS
SPREADING THE